typically a classroom
where we're spending 350 more today
i mean i don't know the numbers in
canada but i looked up in the uk and
it's largely similar
like there's more and more money going
into what is still essentially the same
format and i have grandchildren in
school here and it's the same format
the teacher decides on the curriculum in
fact what we have is
what i call the classroom triangle the
teacher has to teach a curriculum
there are tests to make sure that
whatever the curriculum was whatever was
taught
at the kids that the kids were able to
reproduce it
and the other thing the teacher worries
about is how to keep people busy in the
classroom
so basically the three preoccupations
are how do we teach the curriculum
how do i test if they learn anything and
how do i keep them occupied
in other words the teachers in charge
and
my belief is and this is another book
that i recommend
that's not how the brain learns in fact
the brain learns all the time
the brain is built to learn it'll always
learn it'll learn through
exposure it'll form patterns and it's in
its own in the brain will form patterns
in order that it can deal with these
situations that keep coming out
but the brain decides what it's going to
learn when and
the brain doesn't necessarily comply
with the curriculum that the teacher
or the the order that the teacher has
has decided
and the major issue is motivation
enjoyment
and alertness and so again it's it's a
matter of
training oneself to be attentive to
what's happening but the three are
related if you're not motivated you're
not enjoying it if you're not motivated
and enjoying it you aren't paying
attention so
those are the things that that
teachers have to worry about and
language learning or learning means
changing and there is also
some degree of resistance to learning
because when you learn you change and a
lot of people don't want to change
so if i bring that to the subject of
language learning which interests me
what i have found to be largely true is
what this gentleman stephen krashman
says
and that is to learn a language which is
my interest
all he says all you need is input
that's all you need if you have enough
input
that is reading and listening if you
have enough input
the brain which is used to learning and
likes to learn
the brain will start to form its own
patterns and labels to deal with the
language
and he says you know all the structures
we need to learn are
already there if you provide them with
enough comprehensible input
and of course you can't give people
incomprehensible input
you have to give people input that's of
interest to them
and comprehensible and
therefore we don't eat grammar says he i
don't fully agree
because i do believe that that there are
things you can do
to help the learner be more attentive to
what's happening in the language
because there are certain things you're
going to hear or read
and you aren't going to notice time and
time and time again
so there are things you can do to make
the brain more attentive
but the bigger thing is in my opinion
that we need to
i i can only speak from my experience as
a language learner
we need to kind of explode the
boundaries
and so that we don't deal with the
classroom situation with a teacher
kids in the class primary concern is to
push through the curriculum
get people to you know behave in the
classroom and past tests but that we
have learning communities
more like what
matt ridley referred to where people are
learning from each other
exchanging information languages
experiences and so forth and so on and i
think that is the promise
of the internet the promise that the
ipad makes
more accessible than ever before
and so if we get back to the real
learning
triangle is not curriculum tests
and people keeping people busy in the
classroom the real learning triangle is
attitude
time spent and attentiveness in other
words
if we take the example of language if
you are very motivated to learn a
language
if you believe you can do it if you like
the language
you have a friend that speaks that
language if
if you don't resist the language you can
learn
and if you're willing to spend the time
but you also need to be trained a little
bit to notice
what's happening because very often it
can take you a long time to notice
so with that we now move to what's
happening on the internet
and on the internet now there is so much
content
and i'll show you some examples later on
that
and here's uh an example of
the the little symbol of the ipad but
online dictionaries
online dictionaries with conjugations if
you want to conjugate a french verb if
you put french verb i tried it out
there's something like 653
000 pages you just go french verbs
so you can oh what's your verb the verb
you know done a or something
bingo it's all there all the information
you need online dictionaries
uh you have unbelievable online content
for example russian you have language
courses you have
uh communities where people exchange
language you speak to me in chinese i'll
speak to you in english
uh i write something in chinese you
correct it
uh and there's all kinds of these it's
extraordinary whatever it's available on
the internet and i want to digress a
little bit
from from the language issue and just as
an example of what's hap what happens on
the internet
someone sent me a video
this is in this ted ted series that some
of you may be familiar with
and this gentleman sugata mitra
is an indian educator and he took a
computer
and put it in a wall in a hole in a wall
in a delhi slum and
the local kids came by and on their own
figured out how to use the computer
and then he did he did a number of these
experiments then he had a group of again
indian kids 10 year olds or whatever and
he gave them a computer and then he gave
them this uh
software where you dictate at the
computer and then the computer types for
you
so the kids were they were all excited
at this however
the software wouldn't recognize their
indian accent
but they had access there to english
spoken
you know in the accent that the software
would recognize
which was some kind of english accent he
came back three months later
and they were all speaking the way
those people because they were motivated
it all goes down to motivation people
will learn and his perspective is
that education is a self-organizing
system
and i mean and he has a number of
examples to prove it now
i mentioned this to my wife and she said
yeah but what about those kids that
aren't very interested
of course i mean that is the obvious
question
the those people who are interested will
learn
yeah and i think there uh
that's the big question for teachers
have more than kids but my question is
in the classroom is what they do
motivate for kids or not
and i suspect the objective because it's
more
get the curriculum through past tests
therefore they're not as concerned about
motivating
them as they could be but getting back
to languages
here are some examples rhino spike is a
community where people
on demand record like somebody would say
would you record this for me
in serbian somebody on there will record
it
and they can take it and listen to it a
lot i'll
show you we have a community called link
a lot of our members
who might be studying portuguese or
japanese
if they have texts that they want
recorded they just put them up there but
they then also
if they're let's say french speaking
they would go in there
and record stuff in french and they get
credit for doing so and so forth and so
on
uh when i show our uh
community you'll see that in our
community members
uh contribute content to la to our
library in 11 languages
and the content has to consist of text
and audio
so very often if they don't have a
native speaker
audio they will take the text that they
want get
it someone at rhino spike to record it
then they put it in our library
our members can access it for learning
french whoever uploaded that
gets points on our system for having
uploaded it
live moca is a community where people
can find friends to talk to language
exchange they record things and
native speakers critique